notre premier invité politique et ils
n'ont rejoint c'est laurent saint martin
député du val-de-marne candidat à sa
réélection bonjour laurent saint martin
jeudi et vous êtes content là votre
élection sous l'étiquette ensemble ce
sont les candidats de la majorité
présidentielle vous êtes qualifiés pour
le second tour aux arrivées deuxièmes 6
points derrière le candidat de la nuque
la majorité présidentielle qui arrive
coude à coude avec la nuque avec des
figures de la main chronique ils sont
soit en ballottage défavorable soit
carrément éliminé dès le premier tour
c'est un sévère avertissement que vous
en dresser les électeurs hier toute
façon il faut toujours prendre cette
élection avec humilité ne serait ce que
par la participation encore en baisse et
puis effectivement il y à des messages à
entendre des messages probablement de
renouvellement de méthodes des messages
aussi de fond sur un certain nombre
d'aspects je crois que cela n'est pas
nouveau et ne date pas d'hier soir nous
l'avons vu toutes ces dernières semaines
et puis dans tous les cas que vous
évoquez c'est la continuité logique des
scores à la présidentielle vous citez
les scores dans ma circonscription
mais je fais le même score que manuel
macron pourcentage le 10 avril tandis
que le candidat de l'ani baisse lui fait
dix points de moins que l'union des
gauches au premier tour de la
présidentielle
tant que la dynamique n'est pas du côté
de cette coalition artificiel et puis
surtout il ya un second tour et c'est là
où c'est extrêmement important c'est
qu'à partir de ce matin jusqu'à vendredi
soir minuit à nous de convaincre
l'ensemble des électeurs qui ont nos
valeurs républicaines qui considère qu'
il vaut mieux effectivement continuer
avec un projet de stabilité de
prospérité économique de lutte contre le
chômage plutôt que le désordre et
surtout une union de façade de
circonscription plutôt que de
convictions qui n'a qu'un seul but c'est
de bloquer notre pays et de bloquer
notre projet on vous dit que la
dynamique n'est pas du côté de l'union
des gauches de la nuque et en même temps
et dans la majorité présidentielle fait
quand même sept points de moins qu'au
premier tour des législatives de 2010 7
2 points de moins qu emmanuel macron au
premier tour de la présidentielle où est
la dynamique bien sûr que par rapport à
il ya cinq ans la vague est différente
c'est évident c'est la première fois
qu'un président de la république a réélu
hors cohabitation faut-il le rappeler
nous avions anticipé que les scores
serait différent dès le mois de juin
maintenant il n'y a qu'une seule chose
qui compte aura-t-on une majorité
absolue dimanche prochain à l'assemblée
nationale pour agir le reste pardon
c'est du débat d'éditorialistes et de
calcul
c'est l'avenir par danser l'avenir de
notre nation qui est en jeu pour pouvoir
agir face à tous les risques d'inflation
les risques de guerre qu'il y a aux
portes de l'europe ce ne sont pas des
petits sujets et donc on ne va pas
seulement considérer des questions de
dynamique de petits porcelets dynamique
fait la victoire des tensions sur quoi
va se la joue et saturn travail est mort
dimanche prochain notre pays veut t-il
assuré une majorité forte au président
de la république pour agir ou veut-il
faire confiance à une coalition de
circonstance pour bloquer le pays le
débat il est très simple et d'ailleurs
cette clarification est bienvenu parce
que ça fait plusieurs semaines qu'il y
ait un enfumage terrible dans cette
coalition nubes on considère que ce
serait une union des idées c'est à peu
près d'accord sur rien ils sont pas
d'accord sur l'europe sont pas d'accord
sur l'écologie sont pas d'accord sur
l'économie sont pas d'accord sur les
retraites maintenant on va le voir
pendant cinq jours tous les duels
ensemble du ps partout dans le pays ce
soit à peu près les trois quarts des
circonscriptions qui sont dans ce cas
vont démontrer non seulement des projets
différents mais surtout une incohérence
totale une instabilité total et un
risque un risque d'effondrement pour
notre pays avec sa taille capacité à
avoir la majorité absolue si c'était le
cas pour nous
moi j'aimerais comprendre un peu mieux
la position de la majorité en cas de
duel entre l'union des gauches et le
rassemblement national il ya eu un tweet
fière d'eux
premier ministre elisabeth bornes je
sais pas si on peut le voir elle
répondait à elle répondait à fabien
roussel face à l'extrême droite nous
soutiendrons toujours les candidats qui
respecte les valeurs républicaines c'est
votre cas fabien roussel notre ligne ne
jamais donner une voix à l'extrême
droite est-ce qu elisabeth bonne inclut
la france insoumise dans l'arc des
forces républicaines je crois que le
tweet est assez clair il n'y aura jamais
une seule voie en tout cas jamais un
appel à voter pour l'extrême droite de
la part de la majorité présidentielle
les cas dont vous parlez sont
minoritaires ce sont quelques cas isolés
est donc une façon zen
donc c'est donc ce n'est pas rien mais
c'est très minoritaire et ça pose la
question de principe vous les deux
valeurs qui sont quand même pas
négligeable non plus oui mais ce que je
voudrais dire c'est que nous ne faisons
pas de ces cas là le débat principal
pour l'avenir du pays c'est ça que je
veux dire
la majorité
des cas minoritaires il faut regarder le
local moi je ne connais pas les
candidats je ne connais pas les
candidats dans la grande majorité des
circonscriptions donc arrivé ce matin
sur votre plateau de façon péremptoire
en vous disant qui peut avoir l'appel au
vote faut d'abord le demander aux
tirs maintenant le propos de la premier
ministre est très clair c'est qu'en
aucun cas il n'y aura jamais jamais
jamais là la volonté d'aider ou de
laisser passer leur rassemblement
national dans aucune circonscription
position attendait de la part de la part
d'un camp politique qui n'a pas été
capable d'évoquer clairement qu'il
fallait voter pour emmanuel macron le
soir du 10 avril justement pour laisser
un style et une confusion leur
permettant de prospérer sur les peurs et
de prospérer sur un certain électorat
d'extrême droite je trouve ça assez fort
de café maintenant suivre la consigne
était aucune voix au rassemblement
national
c'est si difficile de dire votez
emmanuel macron pour vous assurer qu'il
n'ya pas l'extrême droite dans notre
pays cités
de la présidence de la république avec
des candidats clairement établie là vous
parlez de 60 circonscriptions dont je ne
connais pas les candidats c'est très
différent ne faisons pas de ce débat là
le débat principal encore une fois
l'enjeu il est ailleurs l'enjeu il est
dans une majorité absolue pour la
majorité présidentielle pour le camp
ensemble hélas oui oui nous aurons
besoin de toutes les voix républicaine
de toutes les voix de ceux qui ne se
sont pas portés vers nous et les
abstentionnistes au premier tour pour
assurer une majorité forte encore une
fois pas pour qu'on concerne nos sièges
l'enjeu n'est vraiment pas là et pour
qu'on puisse agir pour le pays mais
juste un dernier match est ce que ça
veut dire vous fait une différence au
sein de la nuit contre la france en sont
mises d'un côté et de l'autre côté
fabien roussel c'est à dire le parti
communiste le ps et les écolos c'est
différent vous pourriez soutenir cette
différence ce n'est pas moi qui la
créent elles existent ils n'ont rien à
voir ensemble ils se sont ils richard
ferrand 10 et se lance dans une façade
mais c'est ça que les français
comprennent ça ils se sont alliés dans
une façade totalement artificielle pour
obtenir des sièges mais l'avenir du pays
méritent luxe à l'interféron déclaré
dans l'entre-deux-tours qu'ils
partageaient des valeurs communes avec
jean luc mélenchon lui même c'est fini
ça c'est bien écoutez je viens de la
gauche richard ferrand vient de la
gauche évidemment que sur plein
d'aspects nous avons beaucoup plus de
points communs avec certains certains
candidats de la nuque que l'extrême
droite c'est une évidence maintenant
attention il ya des cas de figure il ya
des circonscriptions si monsieur tawaf
qui n'est plus candidat avait été au
second tour je ne vois pas la majorité
présidentielle qui aurait pu soutenir ce
candidat là donc encore une fois vous me
parlez de dizaines de circonscriptions
que je ne connais pas avec des candidats
que je ne connais pas et qui sont
surtout tous tpt minoritaires par
rapport à l'enjeu du pays non ça martin
contrairement à 2017 la république en
marche n'est pas en mesure ne semble pas
en mesure d'obtenir la majorité elle
toute seule vous allez devoir composer
avec vos alliés si vous souhaitez
obtenir une majorité voire une majorité
absolue est ce que c'est mauvaise
nouvelle pour vous ce poids que vont
prendre edouard philippe et françois
bayrou alors vous n'avez pas été
toujours d'accord avec toi durant le
précédent quinquennat c'est la
continuité logique de notre union qui
est une vraie union l'union ensemble
c'est une union autour d' emmanuel
macron un candidat à l'élection
présidentielle
une bannière à l'élection législative
précisément ce que n'a pas su faire la
gauche pendant ces derniers mois ils se
sont écharpées sur tous les sujets que
j'ai évoqué tout à l'heure pendant la
présidentielle et en dix jours ils se
mettent d'accord où ils font semblant de
se mettre d'accord pour une union aux
législatives il est essentiel que les
français comprennent la supercherie
beaucoup l'ont déjà compris au premier
tour il faut que beaucoup plus la
comprenne au second tour nous notre
union la république en marche et
maintenant renaissance mais aussi
horizons mais aussi le modem mais aussi
toutes les petites composantes
politiques qui appartiennent à cette
majorité présidentielle sont unis depuis
le début le saurons évidemment
l'assemblée demain en quelques mots vous
n'aurez peut-être pas la majorité
absolue dimanche prochain la droite vous
tend la main d'ores et déjà ce que vous
êtes prêts à saisir cette main d'abord
nous devons tout faire pour avoir la
majorité absolue c'est une bataille qui
commence ce matin qui va être
extrêmement importante et puis nous
verrons dimanche c'est une élection à
deux tours moi j'appelle les électeurs
des candidats les républicains
particulièrement ceux qui ont été
éliminés à nous rejoindre dans le camp
de ceux qui croient dans la république
les électeurs ils s'appellent les
marchés s'ils s'appellent les
républicains c'est précisément parce
qu'ils croient dans les valeurs de la
république et donc évidemment on doit se
retrouver
nous c'était pas une question de coups
de barres il faut cesser ce métaphore de
gouvernail que vous me posez à chaque
matinale il est temps de considérer
aujourd'hui que ce qui nous rassemble
est beaucoup plus fort que ce qui nous
divise
dans le camp de la république face à un
danger extrême parce que ce sont des
dangers extrêmes que ce soit le rn ou la
nuque et nous devons maintenant regarder
de l'avant pour l'avenir du pays merci
beaucoup laurent saint martin
[Musique]